Blayne your new movie that's coming out
is cut to the chase and I want to just
quickly talk about you had three movies
previously that you also wrote directed
and starred in and those were outside
sales weather girl and six month rule
and those were a romantic comedies right
so now why why the change in genre this
action crime yeah you know I my last
three films romantic comedies right and
a lot of that reasoning is just
budgetary you know it's like I'm doing
low-budget movies my first movie was
$80,000 then weathergirl was under half
a million and then six month was a
million dollars and slowly growing in
budget but always you know being a small
budget movie head basically because I
didn't think I could do anything else
because it's it's way easier to shoot a
kiss than it is to shoot an explosion
and like I just thought that that was
like really my only option between like
I could do a family drama or something
but no action no thriller no anything
like that and then I had this experience
actually with Paul Osborne making favor
which I starred in with his actor
Patrick Day and this is my first
experience doing a micro budget movie I
believe the budget was under $50,000 for
that and and it was intense and it had
thrills and it had a real noir kind of
feel to it and then I have friends a
filmmaker named Zack foresman that made
a an action film called down and
dangerous last year and I was just
amazed at what he was able to do on the
budget so I was inspired by these other
filmmakers who were doing really risky
micro budget things and pulling off
these really amazing films so seeing
those guys I'm like it is possible so I
set out to do that and basically built
the entire film around being able to do
it for this budget so now you play a bad
guy this time whereas before you're
always the the lovable either bachelor
or in some type of a love entanglement
so why why the change why write that
role for yourself well part of it was
budgetary part of it was like you know
in doing an action thriller kind of
thing one of the biggest risks is
you know harming somebody like you know
so one of my actors getting hurt and so
I built the script around this one guy
who gets all the bad stuff happening to
him so I know it's gonna be me
and you know if I get hurt I won't sue
myself but that was part of it but also
like I really like the idea of like a
John McClane kind of character who's
like you know he's an action hero he's
the but he's a real guy right he's
fallible and human and and with max I
just wanted to create somebody who was
kind of an antihero who was stepping up
to being a man really for the first time
in his life you know for the only reason
he ever would to protect his little
sister who's always watching out for him
you know what I mean I like the
characters that are flawed and they're
also more fun to play now you shot the
film right in Bossier City news report
yes Shreveport I'm sorry okay well
that's where you're from yeah I grew up
in Bossier City and at Shreveport is our
big city right next door so we shot the
whole film there and it was it was
really awesome like doing a film in my
hometown because the entire community
really got together to support it I mean
like you know I basically I wrote all
the acting parts for people I knew in
the theater community and the the acting
community in Shreveport and we built all
the locations around locations I knew we
could access but it was great like
people would lend us their cars you know
for show cars they would show up and do
extra work literally people made lunch
for us so we didn't have to spend money
on lunch it was really cool and like we
just did a big like premiere in
Shreveport just kind of to thank fost
thank the city you know for all the
support they gave us red carpet tuxedos
the whole thing and it went really well
so we've got a big support team down in
Louisiana that can't wait for this movie
to come out did you have any moments
where let's suppose you were between
takes or something and it hit you like
oh my gosh first of all I didn't even
know if I could make it in LA or New
York and now I'm back in my hometown
like some kind of weird like thing hits
you yeah I mean there's nothing more
surreal than being on
and shooting a big fight scene and you
know having the blood and the thing and
they we have you know guns with blanks
going off we've got a stunt coordinator
standing right offside you know making
sure I'm okay and I look up and my mom
is helping out with craft service so
they don't I mean it's it's incredibly
surreal it's like these worlds colliding
you know but yeah it's I also saw it
shot six-month rule in Shreveport for a
bigger budget so I've had both sides of
like getting to come home and getting to
bring a production there and cut to the
chase it's much more a homemade movie
like Shreveport is all over that thing
you know six months ago we kind of built
it in LA and then brought it down you
know right okay yeah maybe I'm gay I'm
getting confused because I remember
seeing it and there were a lot of city
shots so I wasn't sure yeah so I was
just wondering how that was because I
mean so many people leave their little
town and and they go to do bigger things
and sometimes there's people that want
them to succeed and then there's others
that kind of like you know maybe they're
obviously living through them thinking
well I don't know if I could do that so
absolutely that happens you know happens
with me I think it happens with
everybody you know you've got people who
are you know staunch supporters of you
whatever you do and then you have people
that are just waiting for you to fail
and I mean I think the more success you
have the more you create the more that
that's a very real balance but like you
know haters gonna hate
yeah I can't imagine anyone hating on
you that's very nice of you to say yeah
but I I know that there there's that
dark energy out there that you won't
ever know but anyway but so yeah I just
thought it was interesting that that
you'd come back then it sounds like a
second time to make these films and just
probably it's got to be a little bit
surreal because you know so many people
end up going back home and then just
getting the regular job and never
setting foot on a movie set again and
now you're making us I take film I take
the LA job and I just go take it home
yeah well yeah I mean you know it
doesn't mean people don't have temporary
lay overs I think everybody that's in
some form of show business has had a
layover or two or however long they last
but I think it's just interesting yeah
that's almost I've been cool and sounds
like your mom
is a very big supporter of you she's
great she was like my mom has always
been a huge supporter of mine but like
one of the coolest things was we were
having a production meeting in
Shreveport it was our day two of
pre-production and my mom asked if she
could come to the meeting and one sure
you know why not
and so we're there and she contributed a
whole lot about organizational stuff and
you know and by the end of the meeting
Mindy Bledsoe is my producer said can we
bring your mom on my claim in like in
what way I don't know production
coordinator and like if she wants to do
you want to and she's like I'd love to
that sounds really fun so my mom was our
production coordinator and she's very
organized oh well I can see where you
get from that you are very organized you
know we've talked before and we've
talked about you emailing and calling
and and you seem very detail-oriented in
that way and that's that's I try to be
well you know I mean you know as well as
anybody that like especially the movie
business it's all details you know you
let one thing slide and you know there
goes your marketing for the movie you
know what I mean it's like how come
there aren't more nuclear accidents you
know redundancy over and over and over
again you know it's like are we sure
that the DCP has arrived the DCP has
arrived do they also have a blu-ray
player okay I have a blu-ray in my
backpack if that fails then we have this
you know and like that's life and the
day you don't show up with the blu-ray
that's the day your DCP you know guys
you learned about genre in regards to
selling a movie Oh interesting I you
know I spent I went to American Film
Market this year to you know help
promote cut to the chase and whatnot and
I a lot of interesting things that like
the the genre film you know obviously is
kind of king in that international
market kind of thing I've always I've
always struggled with because my movies
were romantic comedies romantic comedies
tend not to really translate into
international sales comedy is different
you know I most people who go to
romantic comedies especially foreign
want to see the famous people fall in
love you know and you know my people are
relatively not famous so but yeah the
the horror films and thrillers and
I'm really doing well internationally
you know hey domestically I feel like
it's really about what the movies what
the response to the movie has been like
it film festivals and whatnot like a
good movie can get distribution in the
States no matter what genre it is I
think but if you want to make the money
back International is really the goal
you know I'm wondering when you were at
F AFM excuse me what kind of
conversations did you hear cuz sometimes
you can pick up really interesting stuff
that you can relate to yourself right
when you're in a lobby at a reception
something anything that was interesting
that kind of mirrored the sentiment of
all the filmmakers over there I mean the
funny thing about AFM is it's not really
for filmmakers at all like there weren't
many there one of the reasons I wanted
to go is because I'd never spent a long
time there you know and because I'm also
producer and I have a production company
I was interested in in how it works a
little bit more and I think the most
interesting thing to me is how kind of
antiquated it is like when we talked
last time about six-month rule the
business was completely different then
right and like that was four years ago
and now digital has totally you served
all the things we were trying to do then
and it was on the cusp then but like now
it is all about this digital
distribution and the DVD companies and
the digital companies have kind of
they're now have a system worked out
where people are getting paid like back
then there was a problem with
distributors actually paying the film
makers and now like there's a system
happening again now if M seems to have
this this old-school you know like
huckster kind I like all right I got a
horror movie over here and I got a
religious movie over here you want to
we'll package em go get five of these
set it all right and it's all built on
these really old models of like DVD and
like you know here's our territory and I
don't know it's funny I I don't know how
much I learned except for it's just all
a shell and peanuts game it's a shelling
peanuts outer shell shell game I'm
moving the things around and like
packaging
well I mean that's that's something you
know and and things have changed since
we last sat down in so many ways and I
know you you did scream both the six
months roll in in LA and in New York and
so is that something that you plan to do
with cut to the chase yeah a little bit
different cut to the chase is gonna open
in New York February 28th and then we
start a run in Shreveport Louisiana on
March 3rd and then we are here in LA for
a big premiere March 6th so we're really
focusing more on these big one night
premiere things and because we come out
on VOD March 7th so all of this is kind
of working as our marketing wrap around
to aim at March 7th we're six month rule
we did about nine cities across the
country and what I learned from that is
spreading yourself thin like that and
then all you're trying to do is sell a
thousand tickets as opposed to putting
it out into the world you know and doing
one marketing push and getting that one
marketing push to everybody and saying
okay now all of you can watch the movie
I mean it's just there's only so much
effort and money you can spend you know
and it's better to spend the money for
me on like one big marketing push so
everyone knows it's out in the world as
opposed to I'm trying to fill a theater
in Oklahoma City you know which is
something we did we you know we'd go to
a city we kind of did this like kind of
like a rock and roll tour you know where
I would go and do a Q&A afterwards but
then it's like I know I don't know 15 20
people in Oklahoma City I have to get
them to bring their friends and then we
have to advertising and then and then
the theme of the day what happened you
know I made $800 in Oklahoma City I
probably spent at least that much
getting there and marketing in it and to
what end you know to me the most
important thing now is telling people
that we're in theaters but then saying
get it get it at home you know any mean
it's a it's a different way of looking
at it but but you have New York in six
month rule we did a full week run in New
York and we got there and I was excited
and it was like gonna be great and
opening night
Packt everybody I knew in New York all
their friends were there we had this
great party and went amazing the next
day it was a beautiful day outside I
think three people came to the movie the
next day and it's just like I was just
spinning my wheels trying to get people
in there you know and when the point is
letting people in the world buy the
movie and telling them about it you know
you got to get out there and tell them
about it or they don't know
well what advantage to you having
traveled and done this sort of like you
know Blaine Weaver
you know tour was that people got to
meet you and you get probably built a
good fan base that way yeah absolutely I
mean it really is like I feel like the
reason I keep getting to make movies is
because not to sound pretentious but
it's a brand kind of thing like it's
like I am my movie so I go and I meet
filmmakers and I do the festival circuit
and I build this community of people who
are supportive or interested or even
just know who I am
and and that leads to an audience for
the next film and like I love doing that
I love traveling and you know they're
people that hate hotel life I am NOT
that guy I love going and being there
for the movie and then talking to people
afterwards and getting people's
responses and it's one of my favorite
parts of the whole thing yeah I could
see that being your strong suit as well
and I could see that be why people would
come out I know it is hard to that week
run is really costly and it's very hard
to get that first night sure it's a
party but once that first night is over
is the real struggle right so we're
sticking for the just the one night yeah
you know save some money well we have
red carpets at both New York and LA we
can you know we can do it more if we
only have the one night as opposed to
the the whole week of you know like six
months rule
I let the distributor at the time talked
me into you know huge ads and New York
Times he's like this is how you open a
movie in New York and I listened and I'm
like all right spent a bunch of money to
get this full-page ad you know for the
weekend and the weekend section and then
on Saturday when it's empty I'm like you
know I could have spent one third of
that money on an ad on indieWIRE you
know that we're in New York just letting
people know and here's the presale land
to buy the movie I didn't do that I was
following a model from 20 years ago
and that's that's what this movie has
been for me is saying okay we've done
the classic theatrical model what's
wrong with that
what do we need to do today 2017 to get
this movie in as many homes as possible
going back to what you said about
romantic comedies being tougher to sell
overseas how about cut to the chase
because some of that comedy that may be
lost in the translation of the different
languages well I mean so far so good
like Asia seems to like us so we've
stumbled a couple of territories and
like I think that this domestic rollout
is going to help that as well but like
you know they like the action they like
Lance Henriksen who plays our big bad
guy and so the response has been really
good I'm just hoping that we can keep
the momentum going we're hoping you can
give us a brief profile of how you found
distribution for each of your films from
outside sales weathergirl 6-month rule
and now with cut to the chase sure
outside sales was we didn't know what
the hell we were doing that's a very
important thing about my first movie we
you know I I was doing well acting wise
and like this was that the movie that I
sold my house to finance I you know had
done this cartoon for Disney four where
I do the voice of Peter Pan and I made a
good amount of money and I bought a
house and then I sold the house to
finance my first movie and we had it and
we travel all over the film festival
circuit and spent all this money and
then came out the other side and was
like alright I'm broke I don't have
distribution for the movie and you know
what do I do
so that one was crazy it took about a
year of just like talking to everybody
and finally we landed with this company
and got a DVD deal which again this was
when the the system wasn't working very
well so it was like we got a DVD deal no
money up front but they threw us a big
release party and that was pretty much
it but the movie was out that was an
important thing whether girl was a way
better experience way whether girl got
into the Slamdance Film Festival
we had some cool actors we had Mark
Harmon and Kaitlin Olson and Trish Oh
Kelly who was on the new adventures of
old Christine and they all came out to
Park City with us and that helped
promote the movie and we got a
distribution deal right there and then
we sold to lifetime which was we're
really where the money came in so that
paid back all of our investors and then
we had this huge international deal
where they never paid us so we had to
sue this company in order to get them to
settle for one fifth of what they owed
us again the system just didn't work it
was the kind of thing where people the
distributor's not all of them but a lot
of them would just refuse to pay until
you sued them because they knew you
didn't have any money so if you sued
them and got that far then they would
settle for like one fifth of what they
owe you which is a you know a lot of
them politically this kind of business
is being talked about a lot right now
and in my experience it happens all the
time of like the little guy screaming
yelling about where's the money that you
owe me
and then then saying no no no all right
here I'll pay you one-fifth and you'll
be happy to have it luckily that's
happening less now with distributors but
that was weathergirl so whether girl we
made all of our money back but before we
got into profit we had this problem with
our international distributor six-month
rule we premiered at the Austin Film
Festival film buff came to us film buff
is 'sin Attucks kind of little brother
in the indie film world and they put us
out iTunes VOD and everything like that
it was a great experience we're still
out there with film buffs six-month rule
check it out and cut to the chase
finished the film and we've just been
traveling Film Festival wise and like
having conversations and we met with 108
media and they they seemed down with the
movie and we certainly speak the same
language and they bring us out March 7th
so I'm excited so it sounds like film
festivals are still very important for
you to not only show the film and you
know win awards and and and have that
those laurels there but meet people and
do so
again the meet-and-greet and that that's
part of the following for the next
totally absolutely for me I mean like we
kick-started this film you know and I
raised $20,000 you know and that's from
you know people that I've met along the
way who you know give a damn about me
making another film and like a lot of
that is Film Festival people but I'll
say this as well
I meet filmmakers who I learned from who
become assets to me like you know Paul
Osborne who cast me in favor we met at
the first film festival I ever went to
for my first movie outside sales went
there met Paul became great friends now
like I'm using his house for this
interview you know I mean like he is a
great asset like Zak Forsman met him you
know at Oklahoma I believe and let's see
his movie and he's been an inspiration
to me and like you learn by surrounding
yourself by talented people who push
each other and and give notes to each
other and like you know I can't tell you
how many really great writers I can just
send my script to and they'll read it
and they'll make it better by telling me
what you know suggestions what they
would do or and that's a huge asset so
also you're building a fan base for you
and your movies which i think is super
important in the indie world because if
you don't have Tom Cruise you know you
have to reach an audience and if people
have a vested interest because they've
shook your hand it's just like politics
you know it's like it's harder to vote
against somebody if you've actually
looked him in the eye you know what I
mean so I like going to the places I
like supporting the movie I have the
weird thing about like being worried
about my movie playing when I'm not
there like what well what if something
goes wrong it's gonna go wrong it's a
movie it's technical hey anyways but
yeah I love the traveling in the film
festivals and I think it's good on many
many levels I think it's great to that
you have a track record a lot of people
tap out after one or two this is not an
easy thing and you don't always make
money back and sometimes there's debt
and there's all these different things a
lot of people are like you know what I'm
out this is it and I think it's great
that you had this track record and I'm
sure it's not easy but I think that
shows a lot of people that they can
invest in you because you're willing to
show up again
sure and like I think that's true and I
think there there's lots of times where
I didn't know if I was going to be able
to make another move my first one
outside sales I was so far in debt when
that film finished the festival circuit
I I went back to a bar was working six
days a week was broke didn't have
anything didn't have distribution for
the movie it was a really low time and
then I had this script weathergirl that
I sent to the the lead actress
Trish O'Kelly who had just been in
outside sales as my lead actress and she
read the script and I was asking her for
notes being a man writing a female
character you know I she's one of my
favorite actresses so I might take a
look tell me what you think and she's
like I love this movie I want to make
this movie and I tried to talk her out
of it I'm like no you don't wanna make a
movie I'm telling you like I'm so far in
debt I'm you know and she's like well we
won't do that but so we partnered up and
we raised the money to make the movie
and like I was out of the restaurant
world again you know but it's like it's
funny it it's cyclical and it's always a
risk and I love having a I'd say one of
the easiest things about cut to the
chase for me was nobody was challenging
my being there you know I mean and most
of your career as a filmmaker or a
writer or an actor is like convincing
people that you are separate what you're
supposed to be you know like six-month
rule we had on all la cast in Shreveport
Louisiana and I was the writer director
and star you know and like I felt like I
was proving myself every day not just to
my crew not just to the talent but you
know to everyone you know and so you get
a little ground and people would trust
you and then you know third week was
easy first two weeks was really hard
right this movie there was never that
people were on board from the very
beginning and that's just because of the
track record it's just because they're
like he's done this before I like that
movie we trust him
and not having to gain that faith it
just makes everything so much easier I
want to go back to the story about
selling your house and then working in
the bar and writing the script during
the day I you have to hear that story
yeah so what my best friend growing up
is
guy Brandon Barrera and we he's a big
business savvy guy and I'm the big
creative guy and we he convinced me to
buy to go in with him and buy this house
so we bought a house in Hollywood this
was you know I had money from Peter Pan
and some other acting jobs and we had
this house and then I got into making
this movie and I'm like Brandon how
about we do a production company sell
the house finance the movie he said sure
let's do it we financed the movie two
years later I'm broke I learned about
something called capital gains tax you
shouldn't know about that before you
sell house kids so I got hit with just
dozens and dozens of thousands of
dollars in debt and I think was eighty
thousand at one point and you know I was
worried about having to I had the LLC
for the movie and we had this production
company and I went to work and I was I
moved into this apartment that I call
the hovel and live there worked every
single night where where were you I was
working at the village idiot on Melrose
and Martell okay which is great barn
these the guys who owned the bar they
had just sunk everything they had into
opening this bar and I would come into
work every morning to pick up my tips
like right as they opened and one day my
boss was like Blaine tell me the truth
you have a drug problem and I'm like
what what do you what do you mean he's
like nobody needs 80 bucks so bad that
they get here at 9:00 a.m. he's like
what's the deal and I told him I just I
just spent everything I have and a lot
that I don't to make this movie and he's
like well I just did that for this
restaurant so we were in this same
situation exactly and we kind of became
great friends they were always work work
me let me do overtime to get little
extra money and very frowned on the
restaurant world but they you know we're
such supporters ironically not
ironically we've become very close to me
and those guys and the after party for
the LA premiere of cut to the chase
we'll be at the village idiot which oh
that's great I love synchronicity but
yeah so I was wort writing every day I
get up early in the morning
right and I wrote four or five scripts
that year the year of the Havel and like
it was literally almost exactly a year
because right as the lease was running
out
weather girl came together I was able to
get out of there I got paid a proper fee
to direct you know and I got to direct
Mark Harmon and Kaitlin Olson and Jon
Cryer and Jane Lynch it was like it was
a totally different you know experience
for me and like I did there was a time
where I didn't think that would ever
happen but it was just tenacity and if I
hadn't been in the hovel I don't know if
I would have been as writing as much as
I was and I don't know if I would have
done whether girl so you know I guess it
paid off
so that being sort of in this really
uncomfortable place or a place that you
just felt like this is not what I wanted
for my life yeah pushed you that sounds
like yeah I think so and you know like
what's funny is I have a weird outlet to
it I guess but like when when young
people ask me you know should I pursue
this as acting this writing you know
directing anything in this business
really I usually say we have to look at
it like I'm being an artist you're
choosing an artist lifestyle and if
you're choosing to be famous that's
you're nuts that's not reality you know
you have to look at it say am I willing
to be broke am I willing to have to work
you know several jobs in order to chase
this dream you know and if you're okay
with that then this is the place for you
should absolutely do it if you're not I
bet you there's lots of different
options know what I mean so like I kind
of I try to take it with a grain of salt
just like that's that down spiral lead
to weathergirl which is one of the high
points in my career so so let's talk
about when I don't know how late you
worked at the bar in terms of hours like
- oh yeah sure when you're cleaning up
and so it's like maybe three or whatever
you're getting home yeah you're getting
up early in the morning how much sleep
are you getting oh sleep sleep
especially those days didn't really work
into it and like was the bar just opened
and it was like the the new staff was
always hanging out and drinking very
late and then getting up early in the
morning yeah sleep didn't really work
into it very there
much but like you know another funny
thing about this life is I need to be
able to audition you know and take
meetings Monday through Friday so I'm
working
those are my like I have to be available
right so Friday Saturday Sunday holidays
I'm working so where most people have
the day off that's when I go in you know
and because if LA is closed that's the
only time I can literally wait tables
all day long whatever you know but it
was a rough time it was a rough time I
don't I don't recommend it so how are
you having the discipline to write
especially when writing just takes this
this like concentrated effort and then
when you're in another world that's
maybe a little more chaotic I think it's
hard to harness that yeah no I agree
with that I mean it's kind of like to me
it's you see how bad do you want it you
know how bad do you do you want this
thing it's like if I can't get up and
write in the morning then why am i
waiting tables to begin with you know I
could you know I have a college degree I
go out and get some job where you know
I'm on salary and you know I won't be
able to go to auditions I won't be able
to have meetings I certainly won't have
time to write I'm doing this so that I
can write so if I'm not writing then all
that time waste is wasted you know at
that the night job you know what I mean
does that make sense
yeah like the two things feed each other
I think the more I hate my job the more
I get up in the morning and write any
any bad customer situations that just
really fueled you and you were able to
just put them into the script
oh man first weather girl is literally
literally about a girl in the
entertainment industry she's you know a
weather person and she quits her job and
then can't get rehired because she quits
it very publicly and she has to go wait
tables it's like if that's not it's
literally what happened to me like I
made this movie I was a director actor
hotshot couldn't sell it I'm back to
waiting tables and I'm waiting on people
that you know just a six months
beforehand I would have hired so yeah
like all of those experiences fed into
you know
what weather girl was about to me why I
just want to go back to the house thing
so when you sold the house that do you
mind if I ask what year this was uh 2005
I think oh okay so it was on an upswing
yeah yeah I got out of it just right
before like that would have changed
everything like if I had owned that
place a little bit longer and then the
bubble happened I certainly wouldn't
have been able to finance my movie right
and did you like living there yes place
okay cuz great it's probably a hard
decision to make wasn't no no I was
young and impetuous and you know it was
like I was making a movie it was very
exciting I was not the the hardest thing
about making independent film had 40
years old is I know too much
you know like I'm more scared now than I
ever was in my 20s or even mid-30s you
know it's like now I know that I'm
risking things then I'm just following
my dream and doing cool stuff like I I
love being a part of this club of
directors and producers who have gone
out and made something they've gone
they've taken a blank sheet of paper and
now there's a movie that's that it's a
small organization of people you know
who have the chutzpah and the you know
ability you know to even get it done
much less if it's good so I love it it's
it's a very brave and you know exciting
group of people I think two people are
more forgiving of an 18 year old or 19
year old making a mistake
sure yeah they are of someone over 30 I
think that that's another scary thing
absolutely yeah it's much less romantic
you know when you know a 40 year old
blows it you know 25 year old you just
learning sure before so I just have to
not blow it that's the key were there
ever times when let's suppose things
weren't going that well that you
regretted selling the house and trying
to make this movie knowing that you'd
come from a position where you were
doing well in that sense you have
property in LA that's that's not hard
that's excuse me that's very hard to do
but and then you're in the hovel right
was there times when you said was this
all worth it no no because like a and
like not to say that there aren't times
where I haven't
thought well that I've made bad choices
but not when it comes to the movies the
movies to me are like you know I'm not
married I don't have kids and I most of
my friends would be very offended if I
compared my movie to them having kids
but to me that's what it is like once
it's come to fruition I would never
regret anything that led to whether girl
or six-month rule or cut to the chase
existing egg because it's not just mine
you know that that's one of my favorite
things about directing and you know
being the person that has to go out and
raise the money which is not something I
enjoy of course few people do but I
build a team you know and then they
count on me there's this paternal
feeling that you have towards not only
the movie itself but the people who
helped make it you owe them something
you know it's like you put your sweat
and art into the making this feature
better and it's my job to protect that
and to get it all the way through to the
to the finish line and like I could
never say ah man I wish I hadn't made
outside sales because like outside sales
was the movie that made me a director
you know and the whole reason I became a
director was a bad experience I had on
this film that called manic that I wrote
manic with another writer and I really
didn't like the director and it was a
really rough shoot for me and but it
made me think if this guy can do that I
can direct you know and like I don't
know if I would have become a director
if I hadn't have had that bad experience
on that on that shoot but I did and now
Here I am
you know write four features under my
belt and you know eight produce
screenplays and like I I don't regret it
like there are things that I wish you
know would spin a different way but like
who doesn't not that it was easy to
raise money because I'd only directed
one feature before and that feature had
not made its money back so I didn't have
much of a track record
how has experience impacted your
financing movies well it's a good
question I think every movie is
different when it comes to financing you
know it's like some movies lend
themselves more to like whether girl was
very user friendly you know it was a
romantic comedy it was easy it didn't
offend anybody you know so not that it
was easy to raise money because I'd only
directed one feature before and that
feature had not made its money back so I
didn't have much of a track record but
we had Jane Lynch was a friend of Trisha
O'Kelly's and she had agreed to star in
it once Jane Lynch's in something
everybody wants to be in it so we had a
really great cast built before we had
any money you know which is rare and
I've never seen that happen on anybody's
movie you know I think Jane Lynch being
the linchpin of that that movie was very
specific to how that movie got financed
with six month rule we found an investor
who believed in me like you know me and
my business partner went to the same
high school that he went to and now he's
an incredibly successful businessman and
like I was pitching six-month rule all
over the place and like I don't even
know if he read the script he believed
in what we were doing and you know was
interested in movies so he financed that
and then cut to the chase was this great
amalgam of just like five thousand
dollars here five thousand dollars here
until we and we until we raised you know
over a hundred grand all people who were
just voting on betting on us and that
was a really personal thing like people
just wanted a shreveport movie from a
Shreveport boy and and they got it so
everyone is different though but the key
the only consistent is that you have to
take every meeting you have to talk to
everybody because you never know where
that money's gonna come from and it's
always a surprise to me like we had an
experience where I had a driver for a
movie that I was on and he drove me to
set every day very cool guy liked me
very much at the end of the movie he's
like I have a friend that has connection
to money and I'm like should talk to my
business partner and
we were ended up secret-identity
financed this other movie with the
friend of the driver like who would have
thought but it comes from all over the
place but you gotta always be ready and
hey sometimes you have to ask the
awkward question who you give me money
right and so with crowdfunding it's good
for sounds like part of it but
especially in this landscape it sounds
like it might be tough for now I think
it'd be tough too I mean you know we
raised 20 grand and it was hard
I mean it's work every single day you
got to be out there and like you got to
be hitting people over the head with it
all the time
and Paul Osbourne always says that I
don't hit hard enough but I do I hit
really hard and I was able to raise
$20,000 but it was by hook or by crook I
pulled that money you know and you know
from from a ton of really great people
but I don't know how much more you can
get without some some kind of hook you
know what I mean like the perfect
sweater whatever those things that make
a million dollars I don't know how they
do it but I would love to get in on that
I think I probably wrote that in five
weeks of just getting up and like you
know hammering away in it I'll tell you
one thing that also I think there's a
great lesson in
fleeing your IMDB shows 12 writing
credits I'm sure you've written more
scripts that are just there but of those
films which production taught you the
most about writing and why Oh
interesting uh you know that when we
talked about a little bit earlier
the biggest lesson about writing is get
up and do it you know is like it is a
job you know I I'm the kind of guy that
I like a glass of wine you know I like
some music going that's very romantic
and I'm sure Hemingway would be very
proud but like that's really not how you
get a script done or how you write that
many scripts and I I am always writing
so it's like you gotta get up you got to
spend time with your coffee you got to
look at it and sometimes it's just
sitting there not being able to write
anything that gets you two days later to
where you are where you can you know
answer the question and put it on paper
uh but I love working on all different
genres like that's what's always fun to
me is getting hired to do you know like
a punch-up on a kids movie or here's a
horror film or you know here's a family
drama but like I love getting to do all
of them because I love movies and it's
it gets boring doing the same thing over
and over again so as far as like what
taught me the most I think it was just
it's just being thrown the random here I
I need you to do this suspense action
film for me you know and like sometimes
you'll get a finished script and you'll
fix it sometimes you'll get a paragraph
and you'll execute it you know it's like
so yeah I don't know all of them I guess
it's just the the process of writing you
just get better at it and like that's
something I tell young people all the
time is like you get practing the more
you write so you have to write you know
any mean all the time I know with manic
you said that kind of showed you that
you wanted to direct for the various
reasons right and then with weathergirl
it sounds like being and so in an
uncomfortable situation really pushed
you how long did that script take
whether go that that script almost wrote
itself like when I think of like the the
easiest writing experiences
I think I probably wrote that in five
weeks of just getting up and like you
know hammering away at it I'll tell you
one thing that also I think there's a
great lesson in directing your own
script because you find in the editing
room if there are flaws in your script
in your logic and your plotline you will
find it in editing and it's crazy to me
it's like six month rule I got almost no
notes on that script that script
everybody dug that script like it was
just one of those things like sometimes
as a writer it's just like something
will resonate and people just liked it
they're like he talks a little too much
and you know but other than that I'm
like great but then we got into editing
and I have all of these structural
problems like he has this moment where
he realizes he loves the girl twice now
why didn't I see that why didn't anyone
who read the script say this moment
happens twice but nobody did you know
and like it's made me look at scripts a
lot harder now especially my own like
when is this moment in the movie like
and this has to be this special moment
it can't be duplicated like because we
had to move a lot of things around I had
this this great editor a believe he who
helped me you know streamline that that
story that you know in a proper world
should have been streamlined on the page
know what I mean
so with weathergirl
how much do you think you really I don't
know I'm just I'm just trying to
envision that time for you do you think
with some of the other productions you
were more comfortable and it was harder
to finish it in terms of the script and
in terms of the script I think you know
I didn't have TV I had really it's
really depressing
I had this season of the office that I
would watch over and over and over again
and so like I didn't really have
anything to do except for sit there and
and write which was the by design you
know I didn't get cable I'd you know I
just wanted to work and it was actually
easier then to write than say you know
when you're happy with a girlfriend and
you know it's like that
that's the hardest time for me to write
is when I'm you know happy and busy when
I just moved that from New York and I
love living in New York there's so much
to do it's hard for me to write New York
because I'm always distracted by you
know things that are going on outside
you know or what's my roommate doing
down there you know it sounds like he's
having fun are you drinking beer let me
have some beer so you know sometimes
that that that lonely time is it's
actually easier you know so from being a
bartender I know you're probably busy
making drinks and getting customers
orders but you probably had some moments
when you could see the LA crowd from
this other perspective yeah and how much
did you see some of that and the patrons
that went there even though you don't
really know their personal life right
and everybody's putting on this happy
facade I needed to get out of Los
Angeles after 6 month roll after 6 month
rule I had kind of hit this I was
supersaturated with Los Angeles you know
I've been here for a really long time
since I was 19 years old kid actor went
to UCLA you know like I've been in this
town for a long time and I just need it
out because of I think what you're
saying because of like I saw the
stereotypes I saw the the you know the
la shallowness or whatever and I saw it
me you know which was not good either
and I just it's not what I wanted so I
fled to New York and enjoyed my time
very much there and I've just moved back
here you know for business wise and LA
is different to me now like I have
perspective you know I see that you know
it's not the stereotypes that I was
seeing you know when I was when I was
here before I was painting my own
unhappy picture of it but it's actually
not that better place I think I just
been here too long so and I've heard the
same thing about people that have been
in new oh absolutely
I'm here so I think it's just a change
of atmosphere yeah it's true I have
friends who have lived in New York much
longer than I did you know they're like
I'll tell them how much I love it
they'll be like I try five more years
like well maybe you should give it a
break maybe you go somewhere else
that's what I did but you're also coming
here with a film yeah that's coming out
that has distribution so I'm sure that's
got to feel great it's awesome it's a
different you're coming from
different situation then yeah I mean you
know the thing about like this movie
business is really weird it's really
weird because it's like it has so many
different levels it's like you start you
got the script and you gotta try to
raise the money and then that's the
whole thing and then you get the money
and then you have to put it together and
then that's whole thing I love being on
set being on set is my absolute favor
when I'm on set and then you were
rapping then you're going to post
production which I'm not my best me but
like it's part of it and then you have
to get the distribution and then you get
to do the film festivals and now you're
here literally we get a link later today
for the pre sells of cut to the chase
and then in three weeks it'll be out and
everybody in America will be able to
access it and that's kind of like the
end really I mean will come out on DVD
in June so that'll be a whole nother
thing that we'll deal with but like for
all practical purposes this journey is
ending next month and like I'm just
really excited if not for it to be over
but for this you know pinnacle of like
here we are we made it to the crest you
know good job everybody
what's next clean how many screenplays
have you sold sold sold I would say
maybe five okay five
yeah it's something like that uh I don't
I think only two of them have been made
though you know what I mean like
normally I'm hired to write something
and then it it gets produced that way
where they have a very specific plan for
what's going to happen to it yeah very
few syv got specs that are out there all
over the place you know they just float
around and I've got this great I think
it's great script I that I really love
about rodeo and I've got this other
script about politics kind of like a
Casablanca set in politics and like they
both been out there and people love them
and they just kind of float waiting for
you know lightning to strike and the
movie to take off well how did you sell
your first screenplay dumb
dumb luck I think as far as selling goes
I think you would count manic as a sell
because Michael Bacall and I wrote that
we were roommates at the time and we
wrote the script together and then we
went to try to get it made with each of
us in the lead roles like we basically
I'd done this cowboy movie that Tommy
Lee Jones directed and I played Matt
Damon's little brother and this was I
was 18 and we were in the middle of West
Texas alpine Texas population like 32
and so Matt Damon had to hang out with
me because otherwise I'd just be sitting
in my motel 6 by myself and he's too
nice a guy for that so I got to pal
around with this guy who was you know
every free moment was working on this
script with his buddy
you know like over the phone they were
exchanging faxes and stuff and I got to
read an early draft of Good Will Hunting
and I'm like you know this guy's great
like this is what I want to do I want to
write my own stuff just like Matt's
doing and so I started working on a
script and you know my best buddy and I
collaborated and so we finished this
movie and then we wanted to get it made
and we ended up attaching this director
and then IFC came in I guess bought the
script for like a dollar you know
something like that like literally like
here's a dollar we now own the script
and but IFC didn't want me to act in it
they wanted a bigger name so I agreed to
take a smaller part and they brought in
this little-known actor named Joseph
gordon-levitt to play my part I mean if
you're gonna be replaced by somebody you
really wanted to be Joseph gordon-levitt
but he did a great job anyways that was
the first one and it was dumb look like
I still don't know how that movie came
together
it's like Mike's manager also
represented this director who had ties
with a distribution deal and pulled the
financing together in some way but but
that was it and then we went to Sundance
in that movie so not overnight but
seemingly I went from you know guy from
commercials and the voice of Peter Pan
who's now a screenwriter at Sundance and
yeah that was it and then I went
straight from that to like writing for
other people and getting high
- do you know touch-ups and punch-ups
and you know make things work how many
screenplays would you say you've written
total whether they've been sold or
whether they're floating out there well
if you don't count the ones I've wrote
in my childhood I wrote a really great
movie called the star team which is in
no way derivative of Star Wars but it
might be a little bit but like I started
writing scripts when I was a kid and I
would you know go to shoot them and get
about halfway through and lose interest
but as an adult and since Manik I've
probably written jeez 30 40 probably 40
something like that that sounds right
okay I I mean there's been months where
I've written a script in 15 days because
that's what was required in the job you
know and then I have had scripts that
took me three years to get through so
always a depending on what it is and
what the job is and most of these came
from relationships I mean it seems like
you knew someone who knew someone and
and that's how some yeah I mean
basically cheese which when we got
distribution we were working with this
producer named Steven LaRue Steven LaRue
for outside sales Steven Arun knew this
producer named Mike Elliot Mike Kelly
had hired to meet know Mike Elliot
bought a script for me called peach and
then hired me to write and like you know
that's how it happens actually like I'll
do something or someone will buy
something or option something and then
say well can you fix this script for me
and that's really how it works so I have
like a handful of creatives who have me
on speed dial you know and like I'm
happy to jump in and you know fix their
scripts because we've had a lot of
writers ask us you know if I'm coming to
LA from either overseas or another state
how do I get these contacts yeah it
sounds like almost by maybe even the
acting world it sounds like that you've
built this creative yeah rolodex I know
Rolla day I'm really dating
[Laughter]
yeah I mean you know and there's the my
career is so strange like I am NOT the
archetypal I've got I'm a writer I'm
with CAA and CA gets me the meetings and
I come in and pitch it's like that's
never really been how my career works on
any level you know it's like the the
lead roles I've gotten in films have
been phone calls you know they've not
been auditions I the auditions are the
smaller things that are you know
peppered in to my resume but like the
things that changed where I was in my
career we're always phone calls always
like playing I want you to do this thing
for you but when I wrote this part for
you you know and the same thing with
writing like the the stuff the the best
bang jobs the jobs that have moved me to
a higher echelon have always been like
okay this guy's gonna call you in five
minutes he's a good friend of mine I
told him that you're great don't blow
the interview get the job and I get the
job you know it's I mean it's all who
you know is what they say but I think in
my career it's more than it is in most
people I don't know why would you say
though that a writer should even take
well I mean it sounds like such a
traditional route do you know get an
agent do all you know you're talking
about antiquated before with
distribution right so it sounds like
because you knew a bunch of creative
people and you were also acting and
doing auditions and all that that it
really helped to form these people that
would call you because they knew they
could trust you and that's not an easy
thing here so for someone that's new
coming here that as an as a writer what
would you recommend cuz we get a lot of
questions like that we don't always know
what to tell ya I mean I don't know like
I've never had any luck with the whole
like sending a cover letter or like you
know here's pitch of my script every
agent I've ever gotten has been through
a connection you know
so I think it's about getting into that
world in whatever way that you can if it
was an actor I would be like take acting
classes you know join a theatre company
I think it's not different with writers
I'm just not sure exactly what that
organization is you know like there are
clubs there are you know the blacklist
has this you know website that you can
become a member of send your scripts in
they'll they'll read it and give notes
and stuff like that but like be a writer
you know tell people you're a writer go
to places where writers go you know what
I mean I mean there are great things
that WGA offers these amazing things now
a lot of people can't get in if they're
not WGA but there are things that you
can go and buy tickets to and go to
places that you know successful writers
go and meet those people because those
are the people that can help you yes
film festivals are a good idea - oh
that's a great idea that's true well I
mean for you you're an actor and a
director and it sounds like you really
get energy from being around people but
I know a lot of writers are more
hermit-like
yeah so that's a problem I mean yeah and
I like I dig that but like that's tough
cuz you're not gonna make any contacts
being a hermit like you know it's just
like the the writing like I want candles
and wine before I write but I also have
to get the script done so like like you
know and they're all so there are tons
of competitions that festivals run or
writing festivals so you went a couple
of those awards that can get you some
nice intros you know I have friends that
have had some success with that
how do you structure your screenplays is
there a certain format you follow
formula yeah yeah I mean okay so you
know there are the rules you got that
you got your rules you got your save the
cat rules your you know screenwriters
Bibles rules and the truth is like that
there is this kind of backlash happening
right now that I think is totally legit
because now every script is exactly the
same like if you know the structure you
can pretty much call by the moment like
when something will happen there's like
oh no the bottom is gonna fall out right
now and I think it's very important to
know the rules I also think that it's
also important to try to break them if
you can you know what I mean it's not a
requirement on everything sometimes the
rules are your friends pretty much all
the time the rules your friends and the
truth is when you do break those little
rules those little structural guidelines
people don't know why but something's
wrong you know and that's pretty much
that's a good like six-month rule has a
very strange first act structure I did
it on purpose because I wanted it to be
a little different but we made the movie
that way and then in editing we would
show the movie and the beginning was
dragging because you know the inciting
incident wasn't happening until 2025
minutes instead of 15 minutes do you
know what I mean like these rules we
know them up here we know them in here
you know so it's like when they're
broken something's amiss so you have to
know what you're doing when you break
them if that makes any sense
it does it does what are some of the
other rules that you because you said
there's this backlash going on right now
I'm just curious what what are some of
these other well you know a lot of them
is are about when things happen in the
script like you know beginning of the
second act things are going this way and
then go things come crashing down but
then it's gonna be okay and then no
they're not but then at the end it all
comes back together I mean that's very
vague you know like they're really more
specific but I think the backlash from
riders is that I don't want every movie
to be the exact same you know
structurally I I want it to be different
and I think you know like there's some
I'm trying to think of a good exam
of movies that play with that a lot but
like some movies are just about the
characters and it's a slice of life you
know and you don't I'm working on a
romantic comedy that is a about a guy
who just turned 40 and I want it to be a
slice of life but like in the rules he
shouldn't have to go for something he
should be actively pursuing something
from the inciting incident until the end
of the movie that gives the the the
movie a drive and a you know power and
every time I'm writing especially for
somebody else that's something that's
very important to me but I went and
watched sixteen Candles as kind of like
because I'd like for this grown up movie
to be kind of like sixteen Candles only
different nobody there's nothing
happening
there's no drive at all it's literally
just a slice of life it's just like
she's not trying to accomplish anything
and I love that movie so like that's a
example of like that movie would be very
difficult to make right now unless you
had like a Johnny O like a Cameron Crowe
said I'm gonna do this they would let
him but like that's not a script that
would sell because she's not it's not
following the rules does that make sense
it does yeah I'm just trying to think
back to like I know the sister was like
having the wedding and everybody was
forgetting all this stuff is happening
there's lots of action happening but our
main character our protagonist is not
forwardly driven to do anything she's
smoking she's sulking she does man that
nobody remembers her birthday she's not
trying to fix that you know and it like
again like normally it's great to have a
protagonist who's actually trying to do
something but in this particular case
you can break that rule and the movies
just fine it's just different you know
off-camera Blaine you were talking about
ideas being in the ether the zeitgeist
about writing something that someone
else is already writing and you don't
even know they don't even know why do
you think the story I just think
everything every idea has a moment right
like we're all watching the same stuff
we're all we're all on Facebook we're
seeing the same news articles the same
sensory input is coming across our you
know our brains and like you take a
couple of steps as a screenwriter you're
always trying to find a hook find a new
idea find something and I think there's
just I think it's indefinable I really
do but like
ideas have a moment so I like this my
story is that I had come up with this
this script which was a supernatural
thriller kind of thing and it was a
jumping off from The Da Vinci Code which
was very successful at the at the moment
and so I had this you know idea about
like this clone of Christ idea that was
that was the the big hook and it's a
really good script actually still is
anyways but like there's a little action
mystery thing so agent flipped-out loved
it
fantastic as a long time ago when we
printed scripts so I print it out you
know 50 the scripts and we had to pay
for that I don't know if you're aware
but in the smaller agencies I had to go
and print 50 scripts so anyways feel bad
for me so I printed these 50 scripts I
taken of my age and I dropped him off
and then I go to work at this bar and I
walk into the bar and the bartender who
I work with has a Hollywood Reporter on
the bar and I'm like what's this he's
like I got hired to write a script today
for this big production company big
secret idea secret script and I got
hired for it fantastic you're out of the
bar business congratulations you know
and I look at the article and I think
the title is interesting and it sounds a
lot like what would be the title of my
movie and I'm like what's your movie
about it's like how this clone of Christ
thing and I didn't tell him the idea the
idea wasn't even his he was hired to do
that job but the same day I'm telling
you like the day that I printed this
stuff out to go around town was two days
after he closed a deal and it came out
in The Hollywood Reporter and I think
it's like that all the time you know you
have these competing movies that are
happening at the same time we need two
movies about volcanoes that's a long
time ago two movies about again think
but there's lots of movies like that and
people racing to the finish line because
ideas have these moments and they're not
stolen of each other they're each of us
going our own way with the sensory input
that's available and we end up with the
same conclusion so the moral is then if
you're going to write something do it
now
yeah it's you're sorry and get out there
the moral is you better hurry that's
because he never you never talked to him
about no no never did and like you know
it wasn't even his idea he applied to
get this writing position that was like
an open writing position like it was
top-secret but but like that's what my
agent thought he thought that I had told
this guy and this guy just went in for a
meeting and they said you know put
together a pitch for this and he did and
he got the job I could have gotten the
job probably with my script had things
worked out differently do you know any
mean right but I don't know I just I
think it's funny the coincidence
and it's not really coincidence it's
like if I tell a thousand people the
same facts you know somebody's gonna
come up with the same idea that I have
right and also to world events yeah
exactly shaping our mindset and and what
we're kind of gearing towards right wow
that's really interesting yeah and so
once you knew that when you went home
that night what was your hole with
laughs I mean that is honestly like I've
had you know some crushing
disappointments that was probably in the
top three
it was bad because you know like you
spend so much time on a script and then
like you give it to an agent in the
agents be like ah you have any westerns
you know I mean that's normally what
happens is like you're like ah the
script is hot and they'll read it and be
like you know there's a movie that just
sold a couple of weeks ago that's kind
of this kind of tone what else you got
like well I just spent you know nine
months making this for you so like it's
incredibly disappointing to put work
into something and then have a response
like my biggest criticism I'd normally
gotten for my agents is that my scripts
are not high concept enough like I like
small stories I like stories with like
four or five people you know and all of
my movies that I've made have really
been about three people and you know
there are ancillary characters of course
but like it's a small little world and
that's interesting to me like I my
instinct is not to go and write
Independence Day you know where you have
you know a generals having this in a
reporters over here and you know then
you have characters on the other side of
the world that's not my thing
so when
an agent sees money signs when they look
at one of my scripts that's a rarity and
something that I'm like oh great
fantastic you're happy I'm happy
let's you know go sell it and then for
the rug to be pulled out from under
without the script even getting a shot
that was hard I went to the bathroom I
got sick I freaked out on my manager
basically saying what am I gonna do you
know and he's like what do you mean what
are you gonna do you're gonna go home
and you're gonna start writing something
else I took a couple of days though I
had the wine the next time that I did
right right and the candles and the
candles yeah a calming kind of a sage
clearing yeah exactly clean this you
said something a moment ago about that
was brilliant again you can't luck into
a writing job maybe with acting you can
just because you have that look and you
could play this person or whatever but
you can't with writing we talk yeah well
I mean it's just like I think there's a
you assume that as a writer you've put a
lot of time into this like you you can't
just get off the turnip truck and be
like I'm a writer you have to have
written something and someone has to
have read that and said you know what
this is really good
you should write more you know what I
mean and I think I love writing I love
being a part of that community you know
of people who are willing to take that
journey and like it's because it's a lot
of work it's a lot of lonely time it's a
lot of being productive and you know
it's like you see oftentimes you'll see
actors who haven't put that much work in
you know or you'll see the actor who has
put no work in but just has that thing
you know what I mean and you're just
like man if you didn't have that thing
but you do okay well fair enough
but like you know with writing you can't
just do that ya have to no matter how
talented you are you have to work at it
you have to get better at it all the
time and so I feel like writers kind of
give each other like a passive like yeah
like oh yeah cool you know we're both
writers you know because it is it's a
small club and it's it's not something
that's easy
and we know that about what each other
knows know what I mean you said before
when you were younger that sometimes you
got tired of certain scripts and you
know this was when you were like 10 or
whenever so it's a big difference but
how do you stay with something so you
don't get tired of it in terms of
reworking it doing more drafts knowing
that the idea is really good right but I
mean it's hard it's hard and I I have
this thing that as I get older is
becoming more defined in Who I am of
like there's a lack of time like I don't
have time to waste on something that is
not going to go right so what helps me
now it's a double-edged sword I like to
write on something I'm going to make
because I know that I'm going to make it
I know it's going to continue getting
better because it has to right get the
notes you know and it also had that's
the motor in it because we want to shoot
this this summer so I'll keep writing on
it and getting feedback and you know
trying to make it as complete as humanly
possible before we shoot down side of
that is I should be writing more specs
like you know everybody should be
writing spec scripts all the time in
order to sell them but that has been a
disappointing path to me because I have
these scripts that I love that I worked
very hard on who have it's gotten tons
of great coverage it's yeah but they're
floating out there just floating waiting
for somebody to decide to make them you
know and that's not as for me it's not
as good a fuel as well I'm gonna make
this I'm going to make this in four
months so it better be good you know you
mean like that that whole of like I have
to keep working on it if I want to make
a good product well you also say you
love your new your best your your best
Blaine when you're on site yeah which
I've heard from other actors as well
that they love being on sets that's
where all their friends are that's what
they live to do so maybe in some sense
it's it's because you have the track
record yeah them a lot of people don't
finish them yep yeah it's true I mean
I'm in a good position now where right
now I'm either being paid to write a
script you know which is makes it very
easy I have to do
I have to sit down and you know write or
I'm writing towards something that I
want to make like I need to be more
adventurous and say like alright I'm
gonna take the next four months and
write something to sell but I always get
distracted back on the things that I
want to make right and you said
something about you were told that your
films aren't high-concept enough so you
think it's more character-driven versus
plot driven I think so yeah I I feel
like my my voice is very dialogue based
very character-driven you know I like I
care less about the structure the the
rules you know
then I care about whether it's something
I want to watch you know I mean like I
love the movie broadcast news broadcast
news just kind of meanders you know it's
like you know James Brooks right like
just kind of hanging out like with these
interesting characters and you get to
watch you know Albert Brooks you know be
neurotic and Holly Hunter this amazing
performance but like it's all over the
place I love that I have to rein myself
in from from doing that kind of thing
all the time
when writing story whether you are the
hero
how you take this hero or protagonist
out of their comfort zone and Cheston um
yeah that's a good question um I mean I
love that like the you know weather girl
is about exactly that you know you take
this code is incredibly successful and
famous and you know you drop her into
having to sleep on her brother's couch
and having to wait tables and you know
yeah I love that I love seeing you know
people out of their element and seeing
how they go but yeah I don't know I
don't know like what the process is is
like it's mostly it's just like what
kind of challenges can I give to this
person you know how can i really get to
see what they're made of you know
conflict if it's going along too well
something's got to be messed up you know
talking about how they have this this
Drive in them which in some sense
reminds me of what you're doing is to
make these films but then there's going
to be things they're going to get in
their way
right and test them and ultimately
prevail so do you see yourself as a hero
even if it's a female characters
absolutely I I'm a I'm absolutely an
actor's writer like that's how I come at
it I always think about parts that I
would love to play you know and that's
all of them you know it's like
weathergirl to me
the part that Tricia O'Kelly played was
a great part a part that I wrote the
speeches for like hearing them in my
brain me saying you know obviously this
metaphor but like I want these to be
parts that actors want to sink their
teeth into I think cut to the chase has
some great example that we've got these
two female characters that are just like
so different and so interesting I think
they have some of the best lines and it
gets me excited about it I write for you
know for me I want speech I want them to
be as excited about the things they say
as I am
if that makes sense it does what do you
think is a function of a story um I like
um I mean it's all escapism isn't it
like even if it's not even if it's about
looking at yourself it's about getting
to know something else and being going
away for a while
into this story you know and I like that
I like cut to the chase
to me is total escapism entertainment
like what I want is people on the edge
of their seat eating popcorn and then at
the end of the movie go whoa that was
awesome
that's what I want you know it's like
we're not trying to reinvent the wheel
we're not you know touching on you know
deep emotional you know core or talking
about any issues it's it's just fun now
there are other movies that are you know
that do that but still you're supposed
to be going away and following something
that's interesting there are all these
rules that we can follow that help make
that story compelling but I don't care
how you get there
the key is for me to care you know I
just need to give a damn about what's
happening on the screen you know either
about the characters or the narrative or
where it's happening or why it's
happening but for some reason I need to
be locked in and not feel like I'm
wasting two hours of my life I saw Pulp
Fiction in New York City in 1994 and I
had never seen anything like that in my
life and it made me never want to write
again because I thought I will never be
able to do that and I think about it all
the time still to this day I think about
walking out of that movie and being like
just blown away with with that cinematic
experience and like you know it ends it
inspired me even though I was
intimidated like crazy
it really did set something for me to
work towards
it's still out way out of reach for me I
think it's just a fantastic movie
experience but that time in my life in
New York City
seeing that it made me want to write
like hardcore you know we talked about
outlining do you do do an outline before
you write I'd rather not but usually
that's required for the job like if I'm
getting paid for it they'll they'll want
to know right these days to get hired to
write a script you pretty much have to
write the script like you have to write
like a 35 page outline for a 90 page
script you know turn it in before you
can get hired to write the script so I
when I'm writing for the people I do
whatever it takes to make them
comfortable with it which normally
involves an outline me I I just it's
kind of like for me it's not a musician
but I feel like it's like just jazz you
know I feel when it's time for a change
I can feel when you know we need to know
more about a character it's like it's
very my way of working it's very
artificial to say at this point on page
12 we need to learn that Charlie has a
secret you know what I mean like because
I don't know what that secret is I'm
like do I make it up now or do I wait
until I get to know who charlie is and
you know write that in and like I feel
like the music of it you I just know on
page 12
maybe there's something he's not sharing
with us what and maybe it's this you
know it's just way more organic and I
feel like it flows a lot of times
without lines I'll find when I'm writing
the actual script I won't feel it going
the way that the outline was you know
what I mean
so it's either like I do something false
I'm suddenly writing for me a lot of
times especially the rewrite process for
other people's work he's taking a round
peg and putting it into a square hole
it's like here's a movie I this is an
actual true story I had written a film
that was a beach beach sports kind of
romantic comedy that was set in Thailand
the note I got from the studio was great
love it
only now it's in Bulgaria and it's
Christmas huh
so my rewrite was to completely and
utterly change the entire you know
scenery and what's happening right round
peg square hole and it's like it's it's
like a Rubik's Cube kind of problem it
doesn't necessarily lead to good writing
right like when you're trying to
problem-solve instead of telling the
most compelling story that's that's what
I hate about outlining that's why I
don't like being pushed into a corner by
some random decision I made three months
ago when I was just trying to make
people feel comfortable about what the
movie was gonna be does that make sense
I can ramble about it for the next two
hours because I it's something that I
struggle with a lot when you finish a
script what's your process let's suppose
you've gone through several drafts and
it's for yourself yeah this is not
writing for someone else and you're like
you know what I feel good I've had a
couple people look at it then what's
your process well what's what's cool
about being able to write the movie and
then make it and stuff which is my
favorite of course is that it's never
done like we get a whole new process
like once we get a cast we do I get
notes from the actors I do a
read-through with as much of the cast as
I can pull together then I get notes
then we talk about that then we get on
set and well we'll talk about it then
what's great about being in charge is
that I know I'm not Shakespeare I know
that there's always room for improvement
you know and the key to being a good
project manager or a good director is
like being able to listen to everybody
suggestions and then make a clear
distinctive choice and then stick with
that choice you know what I mean but
like I can't tell you how many times
I've been really happy with the scene
and gotten on set and the actor has said
something funnier and I've just been
like well damn it there you go
you get the line that's gonna be in the
trailer and I did not write it I mean I
had Dave Foley in in six month from kids
in the hall and that guy I mean first of
all the only actor to ever come up to me
and ask if he could do a different line
reading like most actors just changed
the line and yeah I I certainly am not
offended by
you know it's like I've done it myself
but he came up to me and he's like
Blaine I have a line suggestion would
you like to hear it Dave yes I would
well you know I can go ahead and tell
you that you can probably say whatever
you want and he's hilarious and he
elevated every single one of his scenes
which were pretty funny to begin with
but like that and I get to take credit
for that because I'm the director
I let him say that see that's that's how
smart I am I cast him and then I let him
be him
do you use any screenwriting software
final draft I'm a final draft guy okay
final draft is the way to go as far as
I'm concerned okay so can you take us
through the process of using it I'm just
curious
you know what it's now it's just become
so instinctual like I I was writing a
buddy of mine was working on a script
and he asked for help and he sent it to
me in word and I was so it was so
frustrating that I just transferred it
all over wrote it in final draft and
then gave it back to him so you can put
it back and wear it if you want but like
I'm gonna write in my format I just you
know I like the way it looks I
understand the borders you know it's
like I've been doing this for a long
time now I've been probably writing
scripts for over 20 years and that's
crazy to me that I've been doing
anything for 20 years but I have and at
least 18 of those has been with final
draft so it's just my quill and
parchment you know what I mean right so
what's your advice to writers who don't
want to use any type of software they
just want to write it in pages or a word
document I mean I feel like it's kind of
like what's the it's like method acting
you know like I really don't care how
you get there as long as you get there
you know but I think it's easier with
final draft and it is the accepted
industry standard so you don't have to
worry about it looking funny because
executives the number one thing that you
need to not do this is the biggest
landmine don't look like an amateur
especially if you're an amateur so like
if you're just starting out your title
page needs to look right
you need to you know your borders need
to look right it needs to be well
structured it needs to not be numbered
the scenes need to not be numbered that
is a shooting script not a selling
script you know like all of these little
things that you don't know you don't
know you know are a red flag because a
lot of readers and or development people
they're not that savvy right and so
they're looking for a reason to own
their leather chair and if they can spot
something that you've done that's
amateurish you know they'll throw you
right out you know there aren't many
like there the guys that are making
these decisions there aren't that many
of them that are like savvy and I've
been around the block a time or two and
was like I found a diamond in the rough
they're just finding the diamonds that
other people have found you know what I
mean they're like he like this so I like
it too it's great because you know
everybody's worried about getting fired
I think that's accurate
am I gonna ruin my career in LA but
you're saying that that you know it's
it's good to look professional and use
some and a lot of times you give
yourself away by not knowing something
you know and you know nobody gives you
the benefit of the doubt in this
business like nobody there's just too
many people there's too many people with
experience and there's too many people
clawing so like nobody's gonna be like
hey you know there's some typos but man
what a story
they just won't unless you are you know
like Cameron Crowe or you know Quentin
Tarantino and turn in the script would
they change the margins that's the only
way you get the benefit of the doubt if
they don't know you know they were
looking for a reason to hate your script
that's another reason why this structure
thing is so important especially when
you're first starting out because if you
make a choice to change that structure
they will not assume it was a choice
they will assume it was ignorance and
they won't get through page 10 like if
nothing happens by page 15 if the
inciting incident is not there on page
15 writer doesn't know what he's doing
even if that's not true at all I think
that's I think that's an absolute true
statement
how do you choose the titles of your
films oh I'm terrible at titles I'm
terrible at them that's not at all I'm
good at what I am giving pause born way
too much credit in this interview but he
named cut to the chase like I was
looking for a title and he suggested it
that was so mad I'm just like he just
came just like that like he didn't even
work on it he's like what about cut to
the chase I was looking for something
like Kiss Kiss Bang Bang or you know
which I got stuck in my head is like a
perfect title for a movie like this and
I really like that movie so I'm like
something like that that's fun and you
know throwback to like seventies kind of
movies and he came up with it right off
the top of his head but yeah like again
I'm not afraid to use my smart friends
for all of their smarts and then put my
name on it
well like weather girl yeah whether it
was kind of named itself to be honest
cuz it was it's a it's kind of a
coming-of-age story you know weather
girl and she's you know trying to be a
woman instead of you know a girl who
didn't care about it you know she's
growing up and so it was it was super
easy when cuz the way the girls kind of
demeaning you know and she grows up
throughout the movie that went actually
that was me for that game is sort of you
know manic was a very easy thing to name
six-month rule was not that was awful an
awful time naming that movie why I just
like you know like the the writing books
they'll tell you that you know you come
up with the name the logline and the
poster before you even start writing I
just I'm not really that I had this
vague idea of what I wanted it to be I
just seen too many romantic comedies
that I thought were not at all real and
I think real life is funny too so like I
wanted to make kind of a non rom-com
rom-com about you know a single guy and
like all the stuff that single people do
you know to kind of like maintain their
singleness or you know and he has all
these like little you know things like
he never spends the night because it
sends the wrong message and you know
and six-month rule is kind of like the
theme of his urge to stay detached I
guess and yeah and it just we kind of
backed our way into it and you know part
of it was that the number being at the
beginning of the movie puts it right at
the beginning of VOD and things like
that there I have a lot of filmmaker
friends right now who are dealing with
that where the distributor wants them to
have a name that's a B you see like
right at the beginning filmmaker we know
is dealing with that right now actually
where he had to change his name from his
movie which is like a you to an A or B
and he's looking for it and it seems
silly but like when you don't have names
it can really be the difference of
thousands of dollars you know that's
really interesting it was yeah was this
the six month rule and we changed it
with the s and then we change it to the
number six six month rule and it was all
business for reasons but but yeah like
when I named it I had to go back and
rewrite the entire movie making six
month rule a more you know a pertinent
thing but like you know that's the thing
like I know a lot of writers who
struggle with the business side and the
art and like the combination of the two
to me as a producer as well I understand
like I want the movie out there I want
people to see it
I want you know all of those business
requirements to be fulfilled I also want
the movie to have integrity and you know
so it's like it's easier for me cuz I
can balance the two of them I'm not
listening to somebody putting arbitrary
rules on me you know I mean like if I
thought that naming it six-month rule
would ruin it and that it needed to be
called you know the Xavier files or
something you know then I would have
done that but it's a I get to weigh both
and make a choice as opposed to a lot of
writers who are working for somebody
else who were just like that it's
frustrating because I do that a lot too
I do write for a lot of people and there
are times where I'm just like I think
this is a mistake to do this but it's
your film and I will write what you'd
like and very seldom do they listen to
my experience they
what have their idea they want what they
want so I execute it for them and then I
say it's not a good call but okay well
that's being an employee and even if
you're self-employed yeah that's right
and when I write for somebody else I am
executing their vision that's that's
what the job is yeah when you finish a
screenplay on spec what's protocol when
you're done well you finish it up and
get all your buddies to read it until
what you think because this is like you
only get one first read on that and
that's that's hard for me because I like
to get it out there see what the agent
thinks you know as soon as possible and
it's a mistake you should hold it until
it's done
I I have trouble taking that advice but
you send it to your agent or producers
or whoever your contacts are in that
world and you wait to see what they say
I mean it's it's pretty simple you have
very little power over it once they take
it I have this one script that has been
overwhelmingly positive feedback and
notes and has been at one agency for
about eight months you know going
through actors big movie stars reading
it or their people reading it anyways
and we'll wait for nine weeks and then
we'll hear well Matthew McConaughey
passed but that's okay we're going to
what heroes it okay nine weeks later
well what are you here Elson past but
that's okay we're going to Josh Brolin
and it just sits there and people read
it and you know I do nothing I just sit
and I'm happy that these agencies and
these this talent has something of mine
to read you know maybe they'll see my
name on it
what if you don't have the agent or
manager to give it to I mean if you're
let's say or a new writer that doesn't
have a foundation hasn't been in LA that
long you know there there are online
resources blacklist is one of them where
you can send in the script and have it
covered have it read coverage is this
thing where you know it's like a book
report on your script where they all the
studios do that and they'll give you a
little score you know and you can get
you can pay Pete
then do it professionally but I would
say that right now these these
competitions that a lot of like I know
Austin Film Festival has a very
prestigious one but sending your script
in if you win a couple of awards that's
something that might get some leeway in
a sending it to a an agency you know
like normally I would say that almost
never works I've never heard of anybody
being read because of a query letter but
if you have Awards maybe it would work
you know I mean look there's no set way
to do anything in this business like
everything is like a twisty turny you
know chutes and ladders kind of thing so
you just try everything just throw
everything at it and I mean that's how I
finance movies that's how I got all my
movies done you just try everything and
see what works out and be open to
something working working out in a way
that you didn't expect if you weren't
making these films what would you be
doing
you know I it's a good question I I
think about that a lot I feel like I
always had a dream that I would be like
in behind the scenes in politics like
that's kind of what political film spin
is about is about the guy behind the guy
you know kind of working the world yeah
yeah trying to make trying to make good
things happen from afar and I don't know
I like that idea I mean I I liked it a
lot better about three months ago but
you know it's I think there's a need for
it and people that are willing to fight
you know to get in the game and be brave
and you know stand for something I like
all that stuff and like I try to do that
on my sets I try to do that with my
films you know but like we need it just
in the world we just need people that
are willing to take a stand well in a
lot of sense that is a director the
person that you're talking about or no
it's not a spin doctor but it's it's
somebody that's you know grooming and
giving advice and right to the
politician it's a little more paternal I
guess then you know most spin doctors or
whatever but it's the same thing it's
like I'm taking care of my guy like my
actors they're my guys you know it's
like I'm not gonna let them get her
I'm not gonna let them look bad like
we're trying to do something bigger and
what I want is you know the the raising
tide raises all boats that's what we
want we want everybody going up with us
you don't I mean that's kind of off the
topic but that's what I feel like the
job of the director is is like you're
protecting the movie and you're
protecting your team and if anything
goes wrong in that
it's a directress new pit in the bud you
know or fix it well so that whoever that
spin-doctor more paternal spin-doctor
role is my sense is if you really wanted
to do it you would have done it by now
because you strike me as a type that
sets out to do whatever you plan yeah
why I love what I do
I really love what I do you know I mean
like in like getting to tell stories and
then having a team that you believe in
that believes in you I mean it's it's
worth its weight in gold it really is I
am and it means a lot to me you know I
like I could do this if I could make a
movie a year I'd be a happy guy you know
it's like doing a movie every four years
is trying but you know a lot of people
haven't done for movies you know I have
and I love doing it I'll do it as long
as people at me well you mentioned
earlier that you're about to turn 40 or
I'm bout to turn 41 okay well you're a
very young hey thanks but you know and
you and you recall how well like wow I
did something for 20 years I'm sure over
that course of time you've considered
doing other things but because you love
it and you're willing to stick it out
whether it's a challenge or whether it's
great you've realized that this is what
I'm probably supposed to be doing I kind
of you know I have this moment where I
was thinking about like where I am where
do I want to be you know I guess that's
stuff that you do when you turn 40 you
know and I was like you know I'm kind of
gone too far to throw it away you know
like I I'm not really interested in
changing what I do but like now I have
you know like I said I have four
features they have eight produced
screenplays like people will follow me
and make a movie because I've done it
before
and you know one way to do be like well
I'm kind of at the top of this whole
indie film game so I'm gonna set off and
teach history now it's just I feel like
I'm pretty locked into this and you know
I like it and I keep working and you
know doing new things I'm doing a you
know a play this summer that will be
it's a musical so that's new for me but
like really now it's in Louisiana you
know at this equity house down there but
like I have not done a musical since I
was you know nine years old so I love
doing new things and like challenging
myself and like trying to keep the art
popping and do things that scare me you
know yeah I think that's really
important I think so too yeah and and
with that comes some low times and then
some really high times because those
lows are so bad and yeah and then when
stuff works you go it was worth it well
yeah I mean that's the thing it's like
and you know I friends who don't
understand my life at all you know
because the peaks are so high and the
valleys are very low but like the peaks
are great man like I tell you what like
standing you know being in Park City
standing next to Mark Harmon you know at
a film festival or like being in the
middle of Texas making a movie with Sam
Shepard you know or like wearing a
tuxedo in a red carpet event in a movie
palace that was built in 1925 for cut to
the chase and Shreveport Louisiana I
mean that stuff is tried my bucket list
is pretty good you know what I mean
you know it's got its downsides too but
like I I really like the ride and with
that if someone were to take that
snapshot of that tuxedo moment on the
red carpet they probably would think wow
this guy's this is cool like you know
they don't see all the hard work that
got me to that point and the
crowdfunding how long was the campaign
was three months normally something like
that every months okay so all that that
took to get that money plus you said it
was you had some extra money oh yeah
then it was raising money from that
point from the time that we got the
Kickstarter money all the way until
I raise more money for distribution
three weeks ago right so if you were to
take that snapshot so it's a movie of
flavors life yeah and then you backtrack
though and there was a lot of at the
computer alone without the wine with the
coffee right you know well you know I
mean that what's funny is is like that's
kind of our reality now isn't it you
know with like the Facebook and the
Instagram and the Twitter is like I show
people what I want them to see you know
and not exactly what like it's just I'm
marketing me like I market my films and
I think it's very important and I think
that a lot of filmmakers don't do it to
their detriment because we mentioned
earlier the brand my brand you know I
feel like it has a lot to do with why
people will buy the movie you know will
show up for the Q&A well you know and
you gotta keep that marketing going as
well I a friend of mine runs a theater
you know and we do very much the same
thing you know he's a theater guy you
know I'm mostly in film but like we're
doing the same thing all the time where
you know telling people what our company
is what it stands for what kind of work
we're doing and why you should want to
be a part of it you know I mean and like
I know filmmakers are just like I don't
know how you raise money huh like well
if you try and you learn then you have
the power otherwise you have to find
somebody with power and ask them you
know for permission if you take it
yourself you know I don't have to ask
permission for anyone you know and it's
it's a great place to be as far as art
goes why do you think a lot of
filmmakers don't want to do it just
because it's time-consuming it's scary
yes I think I think absolutely I mean
it's it's kind of gross you know it's
like there's lots of stuff that that
goes into you know dealing with the
financing that is not Fonzie you know
like there's yeah I mean you know Fonzie
shells about you know I did this work
with an actor once and I had just done a
Kickstarter kind of thing and I was you
know and he's just like man I just
couldn't do it I couldn't you know put
myself out there and
for money and Bella bond I'm like well
the good thing is if I make a movie
nobody remembers that I bug them on
Facebook you know they just remember hey
I gave five bucks to this guy there's
there's my movie you know but people are
really reluctant to go out on a limb
they everybody wants to be the sure
thing you know and I just it really is
hard when you when you're seeking money
everybody says no until they don't you
know and that's really what it is but
like that freedom that being able to be
the person who like I put this financing
together you know this is my baby so I
don't have to listen to a studio he says
actually Blane we're going with somebody
who's with CAA and was a little hotter
than you right now for this directing
gig thanks a lot for the script and they
can do that they can just you know push
me right out the door but nobody pushes
Baby in the corner
you know what I mean but anyways I like
it I like it and I just hope that
financier keep believing in me just real
quickly what is the Fonzie analogy I
love this yeah well I mean you know I we
were talking earlier about LA versus New
York and I feel like la is a very Fonzie
culture they want you know somebody to
come in and just I didn't practice at
all I haven't had time to look at this
but I'm just really cool I'm actually I
might be cooler than you are you know
and New York they really want the kind
of nerdy you know I've been preparing
for this meeting for six months you know
make it baby want to know that you've
got it together and then you take it
seriously I just think it's a funny
combo and I have I mean I you know I've
been lucky enough to work with some
really great actors who you know can do
both you know or make it look easy
breezy just pop in like Patrick J Addams
is a great example
he's on suits now and I've done two
movies with Patrick and he's totally
Fonzie it out and then in his hotel room
the night before he works he is Marlon
Brando in that stuff practicing you know
getting ready but then everything's just
as easy breezy and you know Naturals
could possibly be you know I love that
analogy
yes great any Millennials out there
watch happy man you'll know somebody's
Fonzie I don't get it grew up on that so
okay yeah
Blaine you're a writer director actor
producer which of these would you say is
your first passion
well my first passion was acting that's
how I came to all this I love you know
dropping in the middle of it and and you
know being able to create a character
and whatnot but like you know I it's
tough to call I love writing for other
people I love acting for other people
but like I love directing my things
because I get to build this team I get
to you know find talent to elevate the
project and you know a lot of people
think it's weird that I oftentimes will
act and direct at the same time to me
that's how I came to it to begin with
you know was like doing plays and
directing them you know when I was in
junior high
you know I'm acting and then stopping
and be like let's do this and it's the
same way now like I'm a kid in the candy
store you know especially I get to
choose the actor standing across from me
right you know I've worked with Patrick
day twice you know two movies in a row
we work together we work together great
so I I put him in a movie for as long as
he'll let me you know and like I got to
do a six month rule with Natalie Morales
who's like one of my best friends now
and like the whole thing of we got to
fall in love and break up and like we as
actors went through that together and as
a director I collaborated with this
fantastic actress to give this great
performance you know I I love being in
the middle of all of it
so yeah all of it I guess I think to the
criticism of of an actor also making
their own film isn't always warranted
because sometimes that's the only way
that they can keep working and I think
that's a lack of a lot of actors they
don't want to do that well I mean the
great thing is is like I mean who cares
like if that's what I want to do and I
go out and raise the money and then I
hire the people and then I make a good
movie you know I like a six month rule I
was more self-conscious about it because
it was a bigger budget
and I don't know I guess it was just
like I didn't want to be that
narcissistic you know actor who built a
movie around himself
acting but now I'm like you know I'm a
good actor and especially with cut to
the chase it was a you know smart
business move because it was a hundred
thousand dollar movie and it would have
been way more expensive to hire somebody
and house them and pay them overtime I
didn't get any overtime on this movie
and you know for you know what I mean
it's like I'm at this point where I'm
like I like I want to do the projects I
want to do and like the next one is a
horror film that I'm not in but if I
decide to write myself part in because
what go do it I love it though it's like
this is you know Mark Harmon when I was
doing weather girl pulled me aside and
he's like this is it right here this is
the fun this is the enjoyment I know
you're stressed out I know you're you
know you really want this to be good but
you need to enjoy this while you're
doing it and like I try to remember that
it's very hard to remember that when
you're stressed out and you have all
this pressure on it but like I'm getting
better at that of like this is it I'm
gonna make the movie I want to make you
know I'm not going to compromise because
of some idea of what somebody over there
might think yeah I I'm too confident in
the people that I pulled together to
worry about something like that and you
know it's like like you said the best
thing about it is seeing these movies
that like me and my collaborators have
made and being like yeah that's what I
did in 2008 that's what I did in 2011
and this is what I did in 2015 that's
how I spent those years and I think
that's legit right instead of waiting
for someone to cast you which I know a
lot of talented people wait around this
town sure they get fed up so you went
out and did it now going back to that
with Mark Harmon what was going on at
the time when he said that to you it was
I believe it was day one on weather girl
and he was shooting the first day and we
had a soundstage
I've never had a soundstage my my buddy
Brandon who was but producer on that
film
and you know we bought the house
together and we did theater together
when we were both seven years old he was
on set and I went over to him and I was
kind of giving Harmon a little tour of
the soundstage and I turned to Brandon
and I'm like do you think anybody knows
that I have no idea what I'm doing
and he's like you're doing great just
keep going but it was stressy you know
his stressy day we had we had this huge
setup with the biggest actors of the
movie and I was a little stressed out
and but he he he's a very kind man and
he you know he he kind of saw that I was
I was more stressed than I was having a
ball and he was right he was right I try
to remember that that's great so you can
still see it in your you can still see
that oh absolutely yeah absolutely and
he's awesome too like he's way cooler
than me so like you know having Special
Agent Gibbs give you life advice you pay
attention